why can't we get in debates debates are
not about whether someone is right or
wrong debates are about ad revenue
that's what debates are actually about
so how do i know that in new york when i
ran i was in debates right i've been in
debates with actual congress people i've
been in debates and i've gone back and
forth
but there was a debate in new york state
we don't use the presidential commission
we actually use the league of women
voters and they had an actual official
debate and in that debate our governor
said i'm not showing up
why he was winning hands down cuomo was
the homosexual remember that was
homosexuals they all loved cuomo he was
gonna win he's the best guy in the world
so he didn't bother showing up to the
debate so it wasn't televised
so i showed up republicans showed up two
other parties showed up and i wanted to
debate henley and no one saw it except
if he were there that was it because it
wasn't televised so what happened the tv
station said wait a minute there's a
bunch of money to be made so cbs said
we're going to do a special town hall
with just republican and democrat that
debate was televised
so if they think they can make ad
revenue they would do it